Well, it turned out
I woke up from such a loud whistling
growing and then such a
loud bang Well, not a bang
and they shook,
I didn’t watch How long did I go to bed
Well, something flew in but I wanted to
sleep
Well, it’s not useful to watch
the girl woke up
[music]
No, I wasn’t scared because I  I just
came back from the war, so for me this is not
new, now the situation in the city is
calm, people are even trying with curiosity
to see what happened, there is
no fear
[music] one
gets the impression that they
want to, as their Western
curators are pushing them, to bite off as much as possible.
Sorry for the bad manners that they
will be able to do and then when all the resources
and human resources and equipment and
ammunition are close to zero,
achieve a stop in hostilities. But we have been
saying for a long time that we want
negotiations and begin these negotiations in
order to replenish our resources and
restore the combat capability of
our Armed Forces,
which  tomorrow he will write in the merchant about